[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est palaleo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux janvier 2024 bonne année à
toutes et à tous les Paléo news de cette
année commencent fort bien puisque Mazan
le le célèbre dessinateur de bande
dessinée qui a couvert les fouilles
d'enjacques dans son dans son petit
carnet Paléo ainsi que dans ses dans ses
livres très connus les Mimos nous sort
une nouvelle bande dessinée sur les
dinosaures qui s'intitule Les dinosaures
du paradis nous avons fait une interview
de Maan qui est normalement sortie la
semaine dernière au moment où je publie
cette vidéo donc si vous souhaitez en
savoir plus à propos du des dinosaur du
Paradis allez la voir et si vous ne
l'avez pas encore fait et bien
procurez-la vous puisqu'elle est elle
est sortie elle est publiée ça y est et
c'est un excellent livre vous êtes
nombreus et nombreux à me demander des
recommandations de lecture pour des
débutants total et bien voilà c'est ça
la recommandation lecture que je vous
donne pour les débutants ce livre est
extrêmement bien fait il est extrêmement
bien dessiné il est très intéressant il
est très pédagogique aussi dans son
approche des dinosaures et surtout bah
c'est un récit d'aventure et ça ça rend
les choses encore mieux c'est les
aventures de Maan dans le petit monde de
la paléontologie donc c'est vraiment un
livre très intéressant que je vous
recommande chaudement on reste dans les
dinosaures avec cette nouvelle qui en a
fait frémir plus d'un qui a suscité
beaucoup d'émotions les Africains
auraient été les premiers à avoir
découvert les dinosaures bien avant les
Occidentaux alors derrière ce titre
racolleur il se cache une vérité et la
vérité c'est que c'est totalement moi
qui suis responsable de ce titre racolur
alors je n'ai pas écrit cet article là
c'est Valentine poignon de de Sam
m'intéresse qu' l'a écrit par contre ce
titre est largement inspiré de l'article
que j'ai écrit à la base dans Z
convation vous voyez c'est ma trogne ici
c'est moi qui écrit les Africains ont
découvert enfin en anglais du coup les
dinosaures bien avant que le mot
paléontologie ne soit inventé donc c'est
un article qui est sorti dans the
conversation et qui est lui-même inspiré
d'un un article que moi-même et mes
collègues avons récemment publié dans la
revue euh dans un volume spécial de la
revue de la géological Society of London
sur les geoheritage donc sur le le
patrimoine géologique donc c'est un
article qui s'intitule Le le les
connaissances indigènes de la
paléontologie en Afrique et qui résume
en fait l'histoire de la paléontologie
mais d'un point de vue africain donc
encore une fois il ne s'agit pas de
réécrire l'histoire de la paléontologie
comme certains se comme certains se sont
indignés en lisant juste le titre de de
l'article de vulgarisation scientifique
sans aller lire l'article de
vulgarisation et encore moins en allant
lire la l'article scientifique original
he il faut arrêter d'analyser les
nouvelles juste au titre alors
évidemment je je je je suis complètement
coupable de ce titre racoleur mais c'est
un c'est juste un titre racoleur comme
tous les titres racoleurs de tous les
articles de vulgarisation scientifique
vous devriez être formé maintenant vous
devriez le savoir donc allez lire lisez
au moins l'article parce que on avait
déjà pris plein de précautions dans
l'article pour dire alors oui les les
Africains ont effectivement découvert le
premier Ros en tout cas le le site
archéologique de bolakla OL
lesoto nous a donné un os de dinosaures
qui a été transporté par des populations
locales jusque dans une grotte jusque
dans un site archéologique donc c'est la
découverte du premier OS de dinosaure on
le dit bien qu'évidemment il on ne sait
pas comment ils l'ont interprété on ne
sait même pas s'il a été interprété tout
court ça on le dit très bien dans
l'article de vulgarisation scientifique
et euh on dit aussi que la datation
donne un âge entre 1100 et 1800 donc
avant 1800 et après 1100 après
Jésus-Christ donc avant 1800 ça veut
dire avant les découvertes de Mantel et
de Buckland donc avant le mégalosaurus
et liiguanodon découvert par les
Britanniques c'est évidemment bien avant
Richard Owen qui a nommé les dinosaures
en
1842 qui a inventer le mot dinosaure
mais c'est pas forcément avant Robert
plot Robert plot qui avait été le
premier à décrire un os de mégalosaurus
dans les années 1600 donc il y a des
fortes chances que cet OS ait été trouvé
avant celui de Robert plot il est il y a
des fortes chances que son
interprétation du fossile a pas été
enfin que que l'interprétation du
fossile
faite par les populations du lesoto é
été plus bête que celle faite par Robert
plot à l'époque bon ça on n sait rien
mais voilà il y avait déjà suffisamment
de précautions qui étai prises dans le
corps de l'article publié dans les
médias mainstream pour normalement ne
pas s'indigner bon bah il y a quand même
des gens qui se sont indignés mais il
faut toujours lire les articles avant de
s'indigner vous verrez j'ai c'est c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'effet pot de chagrin
c'est-à-dire que l'article vous annonce
un truc de fou et ensuite ça se réduit
comme enfin l'indignation se réduit
comme pot de chagrin au fur à mesure
qu'on découvre toutes les précautions
qu'il faut prendre avant d'atteindre
cette conclusion qui est exposée dans le
dans le titre donc c'est faut faut faire
très attention à ça et et et puis comme
je suis un maître troll et ben j'aime
bien troller comme
ça 10 ans sur Youtube ça vous apprend la
vie plus de 10 ans maintenant mais bref
qu'est-ce qu'il y a qu'est-ce qu'il y a
derrière cet article sur la
paléontologie indigène l'histoire de la
paléontologie indigène bah il y a 2,8
millions d'années de découverte de
fossiles en Afrique et ça quand même
c'est pas rien le premier fossile
découvert en Afrique par quelque chose
qui aurait pu s'identifier soi-même
comme un être humain bah c'est celui-là
ça s'appelle le le galet de makapansrat
j'avais déjà fait une vidéo dessus c'est
un galet qui est très intéressant parce
que il a été transporté jusque dans une
grotte on le sait parce que c'est cette
roche là on ne la trouve pas
naturellement dans cette grotte donc
c'est pas quelque chose qui a fini par
accident c'est un galet de rivière euh
vous voyez bien qu'il est qu'il est
érodé comme un galet qu'on a trouvé dans
une rivière il est il est tout arrondi
donc c'est pas un galet qu'on trouve
normalement dans une grotte mais il a
été retrouvé dans une grotte dans des
couches qui datent de 2,8 millions
d'années donc il a possiblement été
transporté par australopycus ou
homoabilis et ce galet bon déjà il a une
tronche il a une tête et ça ça fait
réfléchir beaucoup des paléons
anthropologues sur pourquoi est-ce que
australopiecus ou homoabilis
transporterait un galet qui a un visage
une pareil idolie visage est-ce que ça
veut dire est-ce que ça veut dire neuron
miroir est-ce que ça veut dire un un
niveau de cognition différente de leurs
ancêtres voilà bon il y a ça mais il y a
surtout le fait bah que ce galet il est
fait en banded iron formation c'est du
fer rubané et le fer rubané c'est un
fossile c'est un fossile c'est en
réalité une trace fossile puisque le fer
rubané c'est le produit de la corrosion
du fer F dans les océans à cause de
l'activité photosynthétique c'est
l'oxydation du fer à cause de l'oxygène
produit par les canobactéries qui s'est
précipité dans les océans donc ces fer
rubanés sont issu de l'activité des
canobactéries ces fer rubanés sont par
définition des fossiles en tout cas des
traces fossiles donc avoir transporté ce
galet dans la grotte de
macapangstrat en Afrique du Sud il y a
2,8 millions d'années en faisant cela et
bien les australopythèques ou homoabilis
on transporter la en tout cas ce galet
constitue la première preuve d'intérêt
pour un truc qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
un fossile et ça c'est quand même de ouf
ça c'est le premier fossile ramassé par
Homo sapiens ça ressemble à une pine
mais c'est pas une pine c'est un
orthoser donc pareil on l'a retrouvé
dans une grotte alors cette fois au
Maroc he c'est ce quiindique ces petites
cartes on l'a retrouvé dans une grotte
au Maroc il n'y a pas d'orthoser dans la
roche qui constitue la grotte donc on
sait qu'il a été transporté et ça a été
transporté par Homo sapiens il y a
300000 ans c'est-à-dire par les les tout
premiers Homo sapiens vraiment les tout
premiers 300000 ans on a' pas d'Homo
sapiens plus vieux que ça et comme ça on
parcourt les millions enfin les les
centaines de milliers d'années les
milliers d'années qui constituent
l'histoire des sciences enfin l'histoire
de l'intérêt pour les fossiles en
Afrique intérêt pour les fossiles qui
passent par beaucoup de de médiums vous
voyez on a des objets qui ont été
transportés on a des objets qui ont été
gravés et peint sur la roche donc vous
voyez ces fossiles de ldiacarien ici qui
ont été représentés sur des plaques et
on sait que c'est les mêmes parce qu'ils
sont trouvés au même endroit et c'est ça
qui est fou en fait c'est que vous avez
vraiment ces fossiles qui s'appellent
des hernietas et vous avez ces dessins
juste à côté donc je dire il y a
quasiment aucun doute que ces fossiles
euh que ces images sont des images des
fossile dernier tas qu'on trouve juste à
côté donc de l'edakarien 800 millions
d'années alors évidemment les êtres
humains ne les ont pas vu vivant he ils
ont découvert ces trucsl sous forme de
fossil on a des peintures rupestres qui
représentent des licopodes euh et
évidemment le l'un des cas les plus
connus et les plus fameux c'est ce ce
sont ces empreintes de pas de dinosaures
qui ont été peints par les bchem euh à
peu près à la même époque où Richard
Owen faisait ses reconstitution du
crstal palace je dis à peu près parce
qu'évidemment c'est très difficile de
dater les peintures hein euh surtout
s'il y a pas de charbon dans les
peintures c'est extrêmement difficile de
les dater mais c'est à peu près à la
même époque où Richard Owen faisait ses
reconstitution du crrystal palace donc
ces gros dinosaures massif lourd à
quatre pattes et bien vous aviez les
bchem qui en se basant sur les
empreintes de pattes dinosaur ici
reconstitua le les faiseurs d'empreinte
les les faiseurs d'empreinte qui pour
eux les appelit certainement pas des
dinosaures mais par définition un truc
qui a fait des empreintes de pas de
dinosaur c'est un dinosaure donc il
reconstituait les faiseurs d'empreinte
comme des animaux ressemblants à des
oiseaux et comme c'est des empreintes de
dinosaures c'est comme c'est des
empreintes de théropodes en l'occurrence
bah cette reconstitution est quand même
vachement meilleure vachement plus euh
c'est quand même une une façon de se
représenter les dinosaures qui est
vachement plus moderne que l'espèce de
mégalosaurus gros lourd ball ballot et
avec la queue qui traîne au sol et et
ses grosses pattes il marchait à quatre
pattes tel que Richard Owen l'imaginait
donc on avait on avait les bouchem qui
avaient atteint quand même un niveau de
compréhension des dinosaures qui était
supérieur au contemporain britannique et
ça c'est quand même fou c'est quand même
fou et c'est pas une réécriture encore
une fois c'est pas juste une réécriture
de l'histoire c'est juste porter son
regard sur un autre endroit de la
planète avec un autre une autre grille
d'interprétation c'est tout euh il ne
s'agit pas de retirer le mérite des des
Britanniques il s'agit il s'agit en
réalité de de de juste rapport redonner
du Mérite là où on oublie d'en donner
c'est tout hein c'est c'est tout en
réalité et ce n'est pas que les
dinosaures évidemment je vous ai parlé
d'hélicopodes je vous ai parlé de
l'acarien les les Africains évidemment
enfin les les Sud-Africains les zouous
en particulier avaient découvert aussi
des des EAU du carou donc les les fameux
listrosaurus on sait qu'ils ont
découvert des listrosaurus parce que
cette colline ici s'appelle
tambokazi qui en zouou veut dire la
colline des osmans et cette colline
effectivement est couverte d'ossans de
listrosaurus et évidemment vous allez me
dire dans le carou il y a des lyrosaurus
partout oui mais pas dans le Kwazulu
Natal enfin en tout cas pas dans le le
territoire des zouous dans le territoire
des zouous c'est la jungle
euh c'est c'est un territoire qui est
extrêmement qui est qui est très humide
qui est très chaud qui est couvert donc
de de de forêts très épaisse c'est pas
la jungle non plus j'exagère mais c'est
un territoire qui est naturellement
couvert de forêt très épaisses et en
réalité tambokassi c'est vraiment une
colline qui quand vous regardez le
paysage alentour est assez unique du
fait qu'elle est dénudée vous voyez
qu'elle est quand même très très qu'elle
est très très il y a beaucoup
d'affleurement quoi donc c'est une
colline qui dans le paysage a vraiment
euh sort du l'EOT quoi donc c'est pas
juste ouais il trouvait des EAU partout
il y a une colline qui par hasard
s'appelle tambokasi mais en réalité ça
veut rien dire non cette colline elle a
vraiment quelque chose de spécial quand
vous regardez le paysage alentour c'est
la seule colline qui est dénudée et ils
l'ont appelé tambocassi parce qu'elle
avait tous ces fossiles dessus tous ces
fossiles de l'yrosaurus donc tout ça et
évidemment le fait que cette colline
porte un nom les noms généralement les
toponymes c'est des choses qui sont très
anciennes donc encore une fois on peut
pas dater jusqu'à quand ça remonte
tambocassi le nom
tambocassi mais les toponymes comme ça
c'est des choses qui remontent à très
très très loin on suppose que ça a au
moins plusieurs siècles donc voilà c'est
c'est ça le la vérité derrière cette ce
titre putaclique dont je suis 100 %
responsable ceci étant dit dans mon
titre putaclic à moi j'avais évité de
d'antagoniser les Britanniques j'avais
spécifiquement dit à l'éditeur
n'antagonisez pas les Britanniques parce
que je savais que je savais que ça
allait créer du drama et effectivement
c'était pas ce que je voulais faire en
fait mais il y a beaucoup de de gens qui
ont repris l'article en changeant le
titre et en antagonisant les
Britanniques mais je trouvais pas ça
intéressant en réalité d'antagoniser les
Britanniques moi je voulais encore une
fois il y a réécrire l'Histoire et
changer le point de vue moi je veux
changer le point de vue je veux pas
antagoniser les Britanniques bref si
vous êtes intéressés vous pouvez aller
lire cette cet article qui en plus donne
des munition gratos contre les
créationnistes qui n'arrêtent pas de
répéter B pourquoi les gens ils ont pas
découvert de dinosaures avant chard il
invente le mot dinosaure he c'est quand
même vous avez déjà entendu ça hein au
moins sur desbunkage et pénitence les
gens qui disent ah bah oui comme par
hasard on a jamais découvert de
dinosaure avant d'inventer le mot
dinosaure bah si voilà maintenant vous
avez des munitions gratos contre les
créationnistes de rien et puisqu'on est
dans les dinosaures et ben on remet une
pièce dans la machine nanoyranus
nanotyranus si vous ne le savez pas
c'est le c'est un des grands débats qui
déchaîne la qui déchaîne la furie sur un
Internet et et dans les cercles
scientifiques est-ce que nanoyranus est
une espèce valide de tyrannosaure de la
fin du Crétacé ou pas il y avait-il
plusieurs espèces de
tyranosauridé qui vivaient avec
Tyrannosaurus rex bah en réalité vous
allez voir qu'il y a beaucoup de
d'articles qui sont sortis là ce mois-ci
qui nous qui qui qui apportent qui
mettent beaucoup de pièces dans cette
machine et donc le premier c'est
nanoyranus alors nanoyranus d'après
Nicolas Longrich et Eva Saita alors pour
Saita je connais pas mais Longrich c'est
un grand nom de la
paléontologie nord-américaine et donc il
remett une pièce dans la machine en nous
disant bah nanoyranus en fait si c'est
une espèce valide alors résumé du
dernier épisode on était resté sur un
article qui était il me semble dans
Science qui disait non nanotyranus c'est
juste un tyrannosaure juvénil donc c'est
nanoyranus comme son nom l'indique c'est
un petit
tyrannosaur et comme il vivait en même
temps que Tyrannosaurus rex ben les gens
qu' enfin il y a beaucoup de gens qui
considèent consid que nanoyranus a été
nommé par erreur en réalité on aurait
juste on aurait juste dû dire c'est un
juvénile de Tyrannosaurus
rex mais longr et Saita ne sont pas
d'accord et ils nous disent que
nanoyranus pour eux ce n'est pas un
juvénile de Tyrannosaurus rex c'est un
c'est une espèce de tyranosauridée à
part donc le voici un nanotyranus il se
distinue de tyranosaurus Rex évidemment
par sa taille plus petite par ses
orbites voyez enfin là c'est c'est le
trou pour l'œil voyez qu'il a pas du
tout la même forme que chez
Tyrannosaurus où il a plus une forme de
H chez Tyrannosaurus et vous avez ce
long museau ce crâne généralement grcile
avec ce long museau qui diffère de
Tyrannosaurus rex donc voici
Tyrannosaurus rex voyez le l'œil est en
forme de 8 ici le museau est
proportionnellement plus court le crâne
est proportionnellement plus massif et
évidemment la taille n'est pas du tout
la même puisque nanoranus est beaucoup
plus petit que Tyrannosaurus rex donc
effectivement ils sont très différents
mais quand vous comparez par exemple à
notre cher ami Tarbosaurus Tarbosaurus
qui est le pendant asiatique de
Tyrannosaurus rex Tarbosaurus nous offre
une lignée aon génétique c'est-à-dire il
nous offre une tout le développement
d'un tyranosauridé depuis les premiers
stades juvénils jusqu'au stade adulte
donc ça c'est
Tarbosaurus et vous pouvez voir que
tharbosaurus bah il commence avec un œil
relativement rond euh qui va se
transformer en 8 au fur à mesure qu'il
grandit il commence à avec un museau
relativement fin et court qui va se
devenir de plus en plus épais enfin
pardon il commence avec un museau
relativement fin et long de désolé et
qui va se terminer avec un museau
relativement court et épais et
évidemment avec un petit crâne qui va
devenir de plus en plus robuste au fur à
mesure qu'il grandit donc il y a quand
même de bonnes raisons à la base de
considérer que nanoyranus euh c'est
juste modèle c'est c'est juste un
Tyrannosaurus rex qui serait juvénil et
les différences ne seraient pas dues au
fait que ce sont sont des espèces
différentes mais à l'hallométrie
hallométrie dont je vous ai parlé
l'autre jour dans la vidéo sur Godzilla
les les adultes ne sont pas enfin les
les juvéniles ne sont pas des modèles
réduits des adultes bon alors dans cet
article longr et son collègue nous
disent que en fait
nanoyranus ce n'est pas ce n'est pas un
juvénil de tyrannosaure et les arguments
principaux de ça sont euh les les lignes
de croissance donc quand vous regardez
la croissance en fait de Tyrannosaurus
rex ici hein donc ça commence petit ça
grandit très très très très vite et très
très fort là vous avez la taille le le
la taille indiquée en sous forme de de
poids du corps enfin masse du corps
poids du
corps chaque fois que je dis masse on
dit la masse c'est pas ça mais body
masse bon c'est les Américains qui
disent bodyass he moi j'y peux rien donc
le poids du corps augmente très très
vite et puis on atteint un plateau où
vous atteignez l'âge adulte donc ça
augmente très très vite et ça atteint
l'âge adulte nanoyranus selon eux quand
ils font des petites coupes dans les
ossems pour compter les lignes de
croissance ce qu'on arrive à voir sur
ces figures là voyez hein c'est une
coupe dans l'os c'est une coupe dans
l'os où on voit les lignes de croissance
le milieu de l'os et par là la surface
de l'OSS c'est par là bah quand on
regarde la courbe de croissance de
nanoyranus la courbe de croissance de
nanotyranus elle semble pas du tout
faire la même chose voyez elle fait un
petit rebon et c'est tout ce qui est une
courbe beaucoup plus classique pour un
dinosaure qui n'est pas tyranosaurus Rex
euh donc ça c'est la première chose donc
le nanoyranus ne semble pas suivre la
même courbe de croissance que
tyranosaurus Rex euh néanmoins c'est si
et seulement si on considère que
nanoyranus n'est pas la même chose que
Tyrannosaurus rex si on considère que
nanoyranus est la même chose que
Tyrannosaurus rex on pourrait on
pourrait assez facilement dire que bah
en fait Tyrannosaurus rex il est à plat
jusqu'ici puis monte très très très vite
et atteint ce et atteint son son plateau
ici donc c'est un argument celui-là il
est il est intéressant mais il est
peut-être un peu circulaire quoi voilà
c'est ça ne marche que si vous
considérez que N Tyranus que si vous
considérez ind dépendamment nanoyranus
et tyranosaurus Rex et c'est
effectivement des choses que les gens
avaient déjà pointé du doigt un autre
argument intéressant qu'ils utilisent
c'est la phylogénie si vous utilisez
Tyrannosaurus rex si vous séparez encore
une fois Tyrannosaurus rex de
Tyrannosaurus et que vous faites tourner
une phylogénie des
tyrannosauroïdes donc la grande famille
la super famille des tyrannosaures et
bien nanotyranus tombe très très loin de
Tyrannosaurus rex alors que si lui
c'était le juvénil de lui normalement on
devrait les trouver l'un à côté de
l'autre c'est le le résultat attendu de
faire tourner une philogénie où on a un
juvénil avec un adulte c'est de trouver
les deux au même endroit ça voudrait
dire qu'il partagerait les mêmes
sinapomorphies les même caractère dérivé
propre ça veut dire qu'ils ont un
ancêtre en commun en l'occurrence il
devrait avoir un ancêtre en commun si
l'un est le juvénil de l'autre
évidemment donc ça c'est donc cette
philogénie c'est une indication selon
longr et son collègue que Tyranus n'est
pas la même chose que Tyrannosaurus
autrement ils devrait être ensemble dans
cette philogénie là ils sont très
séparés séparés au point que là ils sont
il est même exclu de la sous-famille des
tyranosaurinés si je ne m'abuse donc il
ferait même pas partie de la même
sous-famille que tyranosaurus Rex ceci
étant dit je déplore dans cette
philogénie le fait bah qu'il manque
Tarbosaurus juvénil c'est-à-dire ça
aurait été intéressant de faire la même
philogénie avec un tharbosaurus juvénil
pour voir s'il arrive même chose à
Tarbosaurus est-ce que le Tarbosaurus
juvénil tombe à côté du Tarbosaurus ici
ou bien est-ce que Tarbosaurus juvénil
irait aussi se à l'extérieur
là-bas juste parce que bah le crâne est
très différent si vous retrouvez le même
résultat avec Tarbosaurus juvénil alors
que par ailleurs vous considérez bien
que les Tarbosaurus juvéniles
appartiennent au genre Tarbosaurus ça
veut dire que votre phylogénie elle est
hyper sensible à l'allométrie donc ça
veut dire que votre phillogénie va
considérer comme des caractères
spécifiques des caractères qui en
réalité sont ontoogénétiques sont dus au
développement tout ça pour dire en
réalité bah qu'il y a rien
d'incontestable dans ce dans cet article
et comme l'ont fait remarquer beaucoup
de spécialistes des des tyranosauridés
sur Twitter je rappelle que la science
ne se fait pas sur Twitter mais c'est
quand même c'est quand même le meilleur
moyen d'avoir un avis d'avoir un avis
rapide de d'une équipe différente hein
d'une équipe qui n'est pas cette équipe
là sur cet article là euh il y a Thomas
Thomas Hz un autre grand spécialiste des
tyrannosaures qui a dit le seul moyen et
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec lui le
seul moyen de définitivement valider les
enfin le genre
nanoyranus ce serait de trouver un un
nanoyranus adulte le problème c'est
qu'on a toujours pas trouvé de
nanotyranus adulte de tous les
spécimenses qu'ils ont observé dans pour
cette étude y compris des spécimens qui
n'avaient jamais été publiés hein donc
ils sont allés chercher du matos qu'on
avait jamais vu avant
et ben aucun d'entre eux ne présente de
signe de maturité évident le meilleur
argument que les défenseurs de
nanotyranus puissent amener sur la table
ce serait un nanotyranus adulte un
anneau Tyranus ou quand vous coupez l'os
et on voit les petites bandes très
rapprochées qui montrent que il est
adulte et que quand il est adulte il a
un long museau il a des gros yeux il a
un crâne gracile cet article n'apporte
pas cette preuve donc euh
personnellement moi je suis de l'avis de
dire bon bah pour l'instant nanoyranus
il y a pas grandment de d'arguments pour
dire que c'est autre chose qu'un
Tyrannosaurus rex juvénil ceci étant dit
vous allez voir que euh nano enfin que
vous allez voir que Tyrannosaurus rex
n'était peut-être pas la seule espèce
euh qui parcourait l'Amérique du Nord à
la toute fin du Crétacé enfin la seule
espèce de grand carnivore tyrannosauridé
qui parcourait le monde à la toute fin
du Crétacé puisque nous passons à cet
article publié dans la très prestigieuse
revue Scientific reports
qui nous décrit une nouvelle espèce du
genre
Tyrannosaurus Tyrannosaurus
macrensis donc marensis qui vient de qui
vient de Macré qui est une une localité
qui date alors qui date qui date bonne
question qui date soit du campagen soit
du mastrichien ils n'ont pas réussi à
décider parce qu'ils n'ont pas réussi à
obtenir de date précise ce serait un
tyranosaurus ce serait un tyranosauidé
qui serait très ancien autrefois connu
d'ailleurs sous le nom de Alamo Tyranus
euh donc il a c'est déjà un animal qui
informellement n'était pas appelé
Tyrannosaurus de façon informelle on le
surnommait alamot Tyranus parce que il
est très très gros euh et il est plus
ancien que le plus ancien des
Tyrannosaurus reconnus ce qui ferait de
lui B si c'est un Tyrannosaurus Rex le
plus ancien tyranosaurus Rex mais là
pour le coup il préfèrent dire non c'est
une espèce différente de leur propre
aveux les différences avec tyranosaurus
sont très très très très très ténus hein
je vous invite voilà c'est c'est c'est
les comparaisons sont là vous voyez il y
a des il y a des eau qui sont légèrement
plus plus Man et puis la mandibule elle
est légèrement plus et puis voyez c'est
c'est c'est des différences qui sont
très très très ténu la plupart des gens
considérent macreenis comme étant juste
un un Tyrannosaurus rex de stade de de
de dimension extrême on va dire il y a
quelqu'un tayor c'était Taylor je crois
qui avait dit il y a Tyrannosaurus rex
il y a Tyrannosaurus Regina donc le le
le Tyrannosaurus roi le Tyrannosaurus
reine et le Tyrannosaurus Impérator donc
le roi la reine qui était plus grosse et
l'Impérator encore plus gros et
euh et du coup c'est ce serait alors la
sauce n'a jamais pris pour Tyrannosaurus
Regina et Tyrannosaurus Impérator
maintenant on a ça fait 2 3 ans que
c'est sorti je me rappelle plus
exactement mais j'avais fait une vidéo
donc voilà je vous renvoie vers cette
vidéo là j'avais fait une vidéo
là-dessus pour vous expliquer pourquoi à
mon sens ça ne tenait pas et pourquoi à
mon avis ça ne ferait pas date le aussi
loin qu'on puisse le dire ça n'a
effectivement pas fait date mais du coup
on remet le couvert avec Tyrannosaurus
macren6 euh et ce Tyrannosaurus macrean
6 donc il est légèrement différent du du
Tyrannosaurus typique mais ça reste une
ça serait une nouvelle espèce de
Tyrannosaurus bon les différences comme
je le disais sont très ténues l'âge au
moins est différent donc on serait
peut-être face à ce qu'on appellerait
une chronoespèce hein voilà une une
espèce qui deviendra éventuellement qui
évoluera vers Tyrannosaurus rex mais qui
est suffisamment différente de
Tyrannosaurus Rex pour dire que c'est
pas la même chose comme pour
Tyrannosaurus Regina et Tyrannosaurus
Impérator on verra si la saauce prend il
y aura certainement des réponses à ces
articles pour dire si les gens sont
prêts à le croire ou pas mais en tout
cas euh bon bah ces deux articles qui
ont évidemment soulevé du scepticisme
sur les réseaux sociaux de la part de
spécialistes et puis ben on verra on
verra si la sauce prend on verra si ça
si ça au moins au moins celui-là
contrairement à nanotirranus qui suppose
les la coexistence de Tyrannosaurus rex
avec nanotyranus celui-là ne suppose pas
la coexistence de Tyrannosaurus Rex et
de Tyrannosaurus macreenis donc ça ne
supposerait pas l'existence de deux
super prédateurs en même temps voilà
c'est peut-être la se c'est c'est
peut-être l'argument le le plus positif
qu'on pourrait avoir pour Tyrannosaurus
macreensis mais on verra on verra bien
encore une nouvelle espèce ici même une
nouvelle espèce et un nouveau genre de
tyrannosauridé venant d'Amérique du Nord
un tyrannosaure qui cette fois nous
vient non pas d'Amérique du Nord enfin
non pas de des États-Unis mais du Canada
tanato teristes de
grutorom et pour faire plus simple je
vais le sapel groot parce que
tanatoteristess de grutorome c'est quand
même de la folie donc je s'appelle groot
il vient d'où il nous vient du Canada il
est plus vieux que que makreen 6
puisqu'il nous vient du campagnen cette
fois donc juste avant le mastrichien
juste avant l'étage finale du Crétacé il
est représenté par des restes vous voyez
assez parcellaire quand même c'est pas
c'est pas grand-chose mais c'est encore
un truc assez maous assez balaise comme
comme animal et bah vu qu'il pareil
c'est c'est des différences relativement
subtile entre lui et Tyrannosaurus rex
dont je ne suis pas capable de vous
présenter que je suis pas capable de
vous présenter de façon convaincante
donc là je vais vraiment vous laisser
lire l'article mais vous voyez la
philogénie ici place une fois de plus
tanato teristes assez loin des autres
enfin de de Tyrannosaurus he vous voyez
il est même plus basé que
daspletosaurus moins basal par contre
que Gorgosaurus et Albertosaurus donc on
est très très proche quand même des des
tyranosauridé de la toute fin du Crétacé
quoi du mastrichien que sont Tarbosaurus
et
tyranosaurus donc on a quand même on a
quand même de bonnes raisons de penser
que tanato teristes n'est pas confondu
avec d'autres tyranosauridés voyez il
est dans une tranche d'âge un peu
différente il il est un peu du même âge
que l'itronax voyez et dynamo alors
dynamo terror CELI celui qui a inventé
ce nom est un génie dynamo terror donc
je s'appelle groot nouveau tyranosauridé
du Canada ami canadien qui nous
regardait voilà vous avez un nouveau
tyranosaurid dans votre dans votre pays
et ça c'est quand même cool ce sont des
choses qui arrivent vous voyez on n pas
tout découvert hein quand on quand on
nous demande est-ce qu'on a tout
découvert non on a pas tout découvert il
reste encore même dans les même dans la
famille de dinosaures la plus étudiée au
monde la qui se fait le plus mitraillé
de publication on découvre encore des
nouvelles espèces voyez c'est pas que du
c'est pas que des disputes sur des trucs
déjà découverts comme alamootyranus et
nanoyranus mais qu'on est pas d'accord
sur comment les les nommer voyez il y a
du nouveau matériel avec des nouveaux
noms qui sortent et pour en finir avec
les tyranosauridés pour en finir avec
tre-rex voilà à quel point est-ce que
Tyrannosaurus rex était intelligent qui
est une réponse alors pas encore publiée
là ce que je vous montre c'est une c'est
c'est un préprint donc préprint ça veut
dire que ça n'est pas encore passer par
le PER review mais bon c'est un préprint
qui au final vous ressort les mêmes
arguments que je vous avais sorti à
propos de cet article qui avait compté
le nombre enfin qui avait estimé pas
compté parce que compter ça voudrait
dire qu'on pourrait les voir mais on
peut pas les voir donc il avait estimé
le nombre de neurones dans le cerveau du
tyrannosaure enfin dans le cerveau des
dinosaures de manière générale donc ils
avaient pris la taille du cerveau ils
avaient pris le nombre de neurones enfin
il je dis ça au pluriel mais en réalité
il y avait qu'un auteur herculano elle
euh elle avait pris les le nombre de
neurones qu'on a dans 1 GAM de cerveau
de Piaf et transposé à la taille du
cerveau d'un tyrannosaure ça vous donne
un nombre de neurones de blab blabla et
en l'occurrence elle avait trouvé je
crois plus de 3 milliards de neurones si
je me rappelle bien 3 milliards de
neurones qui feraient Tyrannosaurus rex
enfin qui ferait du cerveau de
Tyrannosaurus rex un intermédiaire en
gros entre les baboins et les chimpanzés
quoi il aurait quasiment autant de
neurones qu'un babouin voir même un peu
plus qu'un Baboin et à moitié moins
qu'un chimpanzé en gros donc un animal
qui si on fait le raccourci entre nombre
de neurones et intelligence vous amène à
conclure que Tyrannosaurus rex devait
être au moins aussi intelligent qu'un
primate très très avancé très très un
très très bon primate bon dans cet
article B on retrouve un peu les
critiques que j'avais fait dans ma
propre critique sur sur la la chaîne
j'avais fait une vidéo là-dessus cette
critique étant bah que si déjà si on
appliquait la même méthodologie sur un
hippopotame si vous prenez le cerveau
d'un chimpanzé le cerveau d'un
hippopotame et que vous estimez le
nombre de neurones à partir de la même
équation en gros vous allez trouver que
les deux ont autant de neurones l'un que
l'autre et donc vous allez en conclure
que les hippopotames sont aussi
intelligents que les chimpanzés ce qui
n'est évidemment ce qui n'est évidemment
pas le cas donc déjà il y avait ça comme
problème et il le pointe du doigt dans
cet article et l'autre problème c'était
que le raccourci fait entre nombre de
neurones et
intelligence ce que j'avais ce que
j'avais pointé du doigt en disant bah
que les baleines qui ont autant de
neurones que les humains voire même plus
devrai
être beaucoup plus intelligente que ça
du coup devrait avoir dev devrait
montrer des signes d'intelligence
beaucoup plus évident ce que ce qui
n'est pas le cas puisque les baleines
montrent des signes d'intell inelligence
montre moins de signes évidents
d'intelligence que leurs cousins les
dauphins qui ont un cerveau beaucoup
plus petit et beaucoup moins de
neurones donc ça c'est c'était les deux
critiques principales ils les reprennent
là-dedans et ils rajoutent par-dessus
aussi que ils ont refait les calculs
d'herculano ouel ils ont réestimer le
nombre de neurones chez Trex et en fait
ce qu'il trouve bah c'est que il y a
moitié moins de neurones que moitié
moins de neurones que ce qu'avait trouvé
herculanoousel donc
1,5 milliard de neurones maximum 2
milliards donc en refaisant les calculs
en réappliquant les mêmes techniques il
trouve un résultat différent donc en
plus ça ça ça vient encore rajouter
par-dessus on va dire la la sur la
critique de l'article de herculanoel et
enfin il y avait il y avait le problème
qui avait était déjà été pointé du doigt
c'est qui était que herculano el du coup
disait que il y a une corrélation
directe entre le nombre de neurones et
la longévité que du coup d'après ce
nombre de neurones euh les tyranosaurus
Rex auraient dû vivre 40 ou 50 ans voire
même 60 ans je sais plus exactement ce
qu'elle disait mais bref ce qu'avait
déjà pointé du doigt les les chercheurs
de à l'époque qui éta qui disaient bah
non Tyrannosaurus rex on n a jamais
trouvé aucun qui avait plus de 30 ans et
et quand ils ont 30 ans ils font une
sale tronche ils montrent des signes de
de vieillesse assez
évidents donc enfin en tout cas les EOS
montrent des signes de vieillesse assez
évident donc peu probable qu'ils aaient
pas ass l'âge de 35 ans c'était des
c'était c'était des locomotives quoi il
travaillaient très fort mais il mourait
très vite du coup donc voilà ça au moins
ça formalise enfin quand cet article
sera publié parce qu'il est pas
impossible qu'il subisse quelques
changement d'ici sa publication hein il
est encore en train d'être reviewé mais
quand cet article sera publié du coup ça
formalisera tout ce qui a été fait de
critique sur cet article qui disait que
le T-Rex était malac en massinge et pour
terminer avec les dinosaures euh un
article paru dans une prestigieuse revue
Proceedings be la revue de biologie de
la Société royale de
Londres qui nous fait une petite
corrélation toute sympathique entre
l'évolution de la kératine donc
l'évolution du bec chez les dinosaures
et l'évolution des dents et qui nous
indique en fait et bien que les que
quand il plus il y a de bec et moins il
y a deed tout simplement ce qui est
assez intuitif comme ça mais encore
fallait-il le démontrer encore fallait
il faire les calculs et c'est ce qu'ils
ont fait donc une grande phylogénie une
grande
étude sur la phylogénie des dinosaures
qui montre que bah quand les dinosaures
commencent à avoir un bec ça commence
sur le bout du nez et ça s'étend vers
l'arrière en poussant les dents aussi
vers l'arrière du coup c'est-à-dire que
vous n'aurez pas un bec et des dents en
même temps sauf chez les soropodes ça
c'est assez intéressant c'est que les
soropodes ils développent un bec plus
des dents d par-dessus parce que les
soropodes ils avaient des dents
tellement faibles tellement faiarde en
fait que ils avaient un bec par-dessus
alors comment ils ont su qu'il y avait
des becs c'est les les petits
pointillers là que vous voyez sur le le
museau là tout ça tous ces petits trous
là que vous voyez sur le museau c'est
des trous qui viennent alimenter de la
kératine et en fonction de comment ces
trous sont disposés en fait cette
kératine ça va être des écailles ou ça
va être un bec en gros euh et puis vous
avez évidemment les les cas assez
évidents comme les cératopsiens où là
vous avez les les prémaxillaires ou les
deux mandibules ou le l'osrostral en
l'occurrence chez les cératopsiaen c'est
même pas le prémaxillaire c'est l'OS
rostral qui sont fusionnés bon là quand
vous avez une fusion des deux eau qui
sont le plus à l'avant de la mâchoire et
qu'en plus vous n'avez pas de dents
c'est que vous avez un bec c'est vous
n'aurez pas l'os à nu comme ça ou juste
avec des écaills il va y avoir un bec
comme on voit chez les oiseaux et chez
les tortues actuelles par exemple donc
c'est une étude très intéressante parce
que du coup coup ça ça montre en fait
comment le bec a évolué chez les
dinosaures de manière générale et chez
les oiseaux en
particulier avec notamment ben avec
notamment le les gènes qui codent pour
le bec qui vont aussi anticoder les
dents c'est-à-dire que le gène va dire
au bec de pousser et va en même temps
dire aux dents poussez pas et ça c'est
quand même très intéressant et on
apprend aussi du coup que le le gène des
dents enfin les gènes qui codent pour
les dents chez les oiseaux donc sont
toujours là mais pas tous on apprend
dans cet article notamment bah que le
gène les les gènes qui codent pour
l'émail notamment n'existe plus du tout
chez les oiseaux alors que les gènes qui
codent pour la dentine eux sont toujours
là la dentine c'est ce que vous avez en
dessous de l'émaille en dessous de
l'émaille mais au-dessus de la pulpe
donc c'est cette petite petite partie
entre l'émaille et la pulpe c'est la
dentine et cette dentine elle par contre
le les gènes existent toujours pour la
dentine par contre ceux de l'émail
n'existe absolument plus alors ils
existent toujours les gènes de la
dentine chez les oiseaux modernes par
contre ils sont inactifs et c'est pour
ça qu'on a réussi à faire repousser des
dents chez les oiseaux mais c'était des
dents qui n'avaient pas d'émaill du coup
on sort maintenant des dinosaures avec
une étude française dans un donc qui est
encore une une préprint enfin c'est pas
une préprint celle-là c'est une préprof
ça veut dire qu'elle a déjà été P
reviewée mais que elle est pas encore
mise en page donc c'est pour ça que je
vais aller directement à la fin parce
que toutes les images sont à la fin qui
nous décrit un nouveau mosasaur qui a
été découvert dans l'ude en France donc
c'est une équipe française qui a décrit
ce nouveau mosasaur alors des restes qui
sont relativement fragmentaire mais qui
est c'est intéressant parce que c'est le
seulement le second mosazaur de la
famille des pliop platés carpinés qui a
été découvert en France le premier étant
été découvert à eclusievo dans la somme
c'était près de chez moi donc c'est pour
ça que j'en
parle euh donc et il est intéressant ce
ce Plio Platé carpiné donc qui est Platé
identifié comme étant Platé carpus
lui-même parce que il est il est
intéressant parce que il a des traces de
de de charognage voyez qu'il y a des
grosses traces de dents dans ces EOS à
la fois des grosses dents soit de
mosazor soit d'un autre gros reptile
marin et des traces de dents de requin
d'ailleurs il a été retrouvé en présence
de plein plein de dents de requin aussi
vous voyez des des petits toutes ces
dents de de requin qui sont là euh des
hibodontes des lamniformes donc bref ça
c'est il a éé retrouvé en présence d'une
faune de possibl charognard c'est un cas
intéressant et du coup c'est un second
mosasor de la famille des pliop plat
etcpinés en France c'est super sympa on
aime bien et en plus c'est publié dans
une grosse revue enfin ce sera publié
dans une grosse revue cretasus research
je vous invite à aller le consulter
toujours au Mésozoïque mais celle fois
on va parler de de la lignée qui va
donner naissance aux mammifères qui ne
sont pas encore des mammifères ou en
tout cas pas des mammifères modernes au
moment où qui intéresse cet article
puisque que là on s'intéresse aux
ancêtres des mammifères qui vivaient
pendant le Mésozoïque donc à l'ombre des
dinosaures est-ce que cet article nous
dit alors c'est une hypothèse pure il y
a rien il y a pas de données derrière il
y a rien c'est juste c'est pas une
divagation non plus c'est une hypothèse
raisonnable mais c'est une hypothèse qui
est purement une hypothèse voilà donc
déjà je vous annonce tout de suite la
couleur c'est pas la peine de c'est pas
la peine de demander où sont les preuves
il y en a pas voilà donc pour l'instant
c'est purement à l'état d'hypothèse ça
s'appelle d'ailleurs
idée et spéculation he c'est c'est dans
la rubrique idée et spéculation mais qui
est quand qui est quand même je trouve
super intéressante euh cette idée c'est
que en fait les les mammifères enfin
déjà ça se base sur la l'observation
principale que les mammifères sont à peu
près les seuls animaux aujourd'hui en
tout cas les seuls
amniotes qui montrent des signes de ces
naissances c'est-à-dire que quand on
vieillit nous autres
mammifères on montre des signes de
vieillesse alors que si vous regardez un
oiseau par exemple par exemple bah
regardez d'abord les mammifères donc
nous quand on vieillit on a les cheveux
qui deviennent blanc on a des rides on
perd en force physique alors que quand
on regarde les autres animaux comme les
oiseaux quand vous regardez un oiseau
c'est même un vieil oiseau dans
notamment dans les EAU il y a certains
oiseaux qui peuvent atteindre l'âge de
30 ans tu vois des des perroquets par
exemple qui peuvent atteindre l'âge de
50 ans voire plus il y a des perroquets
dont on ne connaît juste pas parce
qu'ils ont toujours été là dans les EAU
euh bref quand on regarde les les
oiseaux par exemple il ne montrent pas
de signes de vieillesse évident leurs
plumes deviennent pas blanches et quand
vous et c'est pareil quand vous regardez
les reptiles les signes de ces naissance
chez les reptiles ça ne se voit pas et
cetera et cetera alors que chez les
mammifères ça se voit vachement euh vous
pouvez reconnaître un vieux chien quand
vous en voyez un vous pouvez reconnaître
un vieux chat quand vous en voyez un euh
bref c'est c'est c'est ça le la grosse
idée euh et puis c'est encore pire quand
on regarde les poissons bon là on parle
des amniotes donc on va pas regarder les
poissons mais c'est encore pire quand on
parle des poissons regarder les requins
qui n'ont même pas le cancer je dire bon
il y a les voilà les les les signes de
ses naissances c'est ça tout ça c'est
les signes de ses naissances et plus on
se rapproche des mammifères et plus il
montre de signes de ses naissances et on
et du coup ce Yao Pedro des des
machiales je ne sais pas comment ça se
dit s'il y a des Portugais dans la salle
ou des Brésiliens s'il vous plaît
dites-moi comment ça se prononce
euh donc Yao Pedro
deales marales aucune idée euh nous dit
qu'en fait bah c'est ce qu'il appelle le
goulet le goulot d'étranglement de la
longévité donc de même que chez les
ancêtres des mammifères pendant le
Mésozoïque vu qu'ils se sont adaptés à
la vie nocturne pour échapper au
dinosaures en tout cas c'est le scénario
qu'on a dans la tête sétant adapté à la
vie nocturne pour échapper au dinosaures
il y a ce qu'on appelle le goulet
d'étranglement du Mésozoïque qui euh qui
fait qu'en fait tous les mammifères sont
devenus petits et tous les mammifères
sont devenus nocturnes et c'est pour ça
que les la plupart des mammifères
modernes ont une vision bichromatique
alors que tous les autres euh tous les
autres amiotes ont une vision
quadrichromatique donc nous en gros les
mammifères voient en deux couleurs je
très très grossis hein très simplifiés
les mammifères VO en deux couleurs à
part les primates euh et les et les
monotrèmes
alors que tous les autres animaux
terrestres voient en quatre couleurs
donc notre vision est à chier voilà et
ça vient du fait que on avait des
ancêtres nocturnes mésozoïques qui
vivaient la nuit à l'ombre des
dinosaures et puis tous les mammifères
du coup étaient aussi petit donc il y a
aussi eu un goulot d'étranglement au
niveau de la taille et donc ce qu'il
propose là c'est un goulot
d'étranglement qui a aussi touché notre
longévité à savoir que quand vous êtes
tout petit et que vous êtes au menu d'à
peu près tout ce qui est vivant bah ça
sert à rien de vivre vieux voilà et ça
ça ça rejoint une vidéo qu'on avait fait
avec ah bah sur trraacte Scien qu'on
avait fait à propos de l'origine
évolutive de la mort donc je vous invite
à aller voir cette vidéo sur l'origine
évolutive de la mort parce que elle
explique en fait pourquoi on meurt
pourquoi on vieillit et pourquoi on
meurt et ça c'est une question évolutive
qui est extrêmement intéressante parce
que justement ça touche ça touche au
darwinisme à l'essence M du darwinisme
en réalité c'està-dire que si le but
c'était de se reproduire le plus
possible bah l'intérêt c'est de vivre le
plus longtemps possible pour produire le
plus de gamè possible pour avoir le plus
de bébés poss possible donc vieillir et
donc perdre sa fertilité et mourir donc
ne plus laisser aucun descendant c'est
complètement contreintuitif dans un dans
un contexte darwinien l'intérêt ce
serait de produire le plus de
descendants tout le temps de vivre le
plus longtemps pour produire le plus de
descendants et surtout de ne pas
vieillir pour que tout le temps qu'on
vit on le passe à produire des
descendants bon bah c'est pas le cas
chez les mamifères les mammifères ils
finissent par avoir par être ménopausé
et euh et ils vieillissent et ils se
rabougrissent avant de mourir et ils
meurent relativement jeunes comparé à
leurs cousins euh reptiliens et avien
euh en tout cas cas à des stades
équivalents de développement enfin à des
à des oui si en tout cas à des stades
équivalents de de leur de leur de leur
âge de leur développement oui donc
pourquoi est-ce qu'on est précoce comme
ça chez les mammifères pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait n'importe quoi et ben ce
serait dû au fait que bah comme on était
comme on est tous descendants de tout
petits animaux des animaux qui étaient
pas forcément tout en bas de la chaîne
alimentaire mais qui étaient au menu d'à
peu près tout ce qui était plus grand
queeux c'est-à-dire tout et ben au
Mésozoïque c'est devenu complètement
inutile aux ancêtres des mammifères de
vivre longtemps pensez à une souris hein
le potentiel qu' a une souris ou un ou
un je sais pas ou un cochon d'inde de
vivre plus de 5
ans c'est pas top c'est pas ouf les les
les prospectives d'avenir sont pas
gigantesques donc autant produire un max
de bébé hein tant qu'on peut et puis et
surtout avant qu'on crève ça veut dire
que naturellement en fait la sélection
naturelle va tout miser sur les
premières années de la vie donc il va y
avoir augmentation de la fertilité mais
il va y avoir un relâchement de la
sélection naturelle sur la période de
vie que quasiment aucun individu
n'arrive à dépasser parce qu'ils se font
tous bouffer avant donc si les les les
chances pour une souris de de survivre
plus de 5 ans sont de seulement 5 % bah
dans 95 % des cas votre souris sera
bouffée avant l'âge de 5 ans et donc
tous les gènes qui vont permettre à une
souris de vivre en bonne santé passer
l'âge de 5 ans vont commencer à pourrir
en fait en fait tous ces gènes vont
commencer à se à se détériorer parce que
il y aura plus de sélection naturelle
dessus toutes les souris crèvent avant
ça donc il y a plus de sélection
naturelle dessus donc tous ces gènes
pourrissent et donc tous ces gènes qui
permettent la longévité et bien
disparaissent sauf que une fois que vous
avez passé le Mésozoïque que les
dinosaures les grands dinosaures
nonaviens ont disparu et que les
mammifères redeviennent les dominants
sur la
planète et ben à ce moment-là en fait
les les les mammifères vont devenir plus
gros vont devenir du coup vont ne vont
plus avoir cette contrainte sur leur
longévité mais par contre leurs gènees
pourr ils resteront pourri donc en fait
ils vont se mettre à vivre plus
longtemps mais par contre la pourrissure
de leur gène on ils arriveront pas à la
réparer une fois qu'un gène est devenu
défaillant c'est très compliqué de faire
marche arrière c'est possible mais c'est
très compliqué il faut énormément de
sélection naturelle une très très forte
sélection naturel dessus et c'est pour
ça du coup que les mammifères même quand
ils sont de grande taille aujourd'hui
produisent des grands signes de ces
naissances des d'importants signes de
ces naissances parce que ils ont hérité
tous leurs gè moisis de leur ancêtre
Mésozoïque en tout cas c'est ce que cet
article là propose donc c'est c'est très
intéressant c'est très intéressant comme
hypothèse et je suis très très curieux
de voir ce que ça va donner plus tard en
même temps sur la longévité il y a un
autre article qui a été publié dans EIF
euh bon c'est pareil c'est c'est une
préprint là en l'occurrence mais c'est
une préprint qui a été reviewée donc le
contenu final ne changera pas de ce que
je suis en train de vous montrer et
c'est un article paru dans la revue
eife qui nous dit qu'en fait bah cette
cette longévité réduite chez les
mammifères elle est intimement corrélée
aussi à une augmentation de la fertilité
donc ils ont fait beaucoup de calculs et
je suis incapable de comprendre la
moitié de ce qu'ils ont fait donc je
vous laisse aller lire l'article mais en
gros l'essence de cet article c'est euh
que le la longévité une longévité
réduite et une sénaissance accrue du
coup vont de paire avec une augmentation
de la fertilité donc c'est ce que je
vous disais quand vous vivez quand quand
quand votre espérance de vie de toute
façon de votre vos chance de ne pas vous
faire bouffer ne dépasse pas 5 ans bah
vous avez la sélection naturelle va
automatiquement miser sur un max de
reproduction pendant le début de votre
vie reproduis-toi vite vite vite vite
vite vite vite vite vite avant de crever
c'est ça que la sélection naturelle va
faire et ce qu'ils disent en gros c'est
que ça a atteint à un tel point en fait
cette sélection ça atteint à tel point
que maintenant les gênnes de la
longévité et les gênnes de la fertilité
sont connecté c'està-dire que vous ne
pouvez plus augmenter la longévité sans
faire baisser la fertilité et moi je
trouve ça hallucinant je trouve ça
hallucinant en fait que ça a atteint un
tel point en fait ça ça et et surtout je
vous invite à réfléchir à cogiter sur le
fait à quel point c'est dans un contexte
darwinien hyper
contreintuitif et encore une fois je
vous invite à aller voir notre vidéo qui
explique justement pourquoi c'est
contreintuitif mais pourquoi en fait
c'est logique entrons maintenant dans le
cénnozoïque on quitte mes prémamaliens
chéris et nous atteignons les mammifères
les vrais euh du scénosoïque et
notamment les mammifères de la
transition etocè higocè en Europe ou une
équipe principalement française en
réalité principalement montpeliieren de
l'Université de Montpellier euh nous
propose une nouvelle étude des fossiles
d'arciodactyle du Kery alors les
arciodacctyles c'est la famille des
ruminants des chameaux des cochons des C
assé aussi d'ailleurs euh donc c'est
c'est la c'est une famille de de
mammifèr terrestre majoritairement
herbivore et donc ce qu'on nous et ils
ont étudié ceux qui ont étit fossilisés
dans le kersy le kersy qui est cette
région de de France où il y a beaucoup
de grottes qui datent de cette période
justement à la transition eosè au
liigocè enfin les les les grottes sont
remplies avec des restes qui viennent de
cette transition entre l'éocen et l'
liigocen et ce kerci du coup ça nous a
donné énormément d'informations sur ce
qui se passait pendant ce cette période
là une période qui a notamment connu si
vous avez vu la vidéo de simplex palaleo
la grande coupure la grande coupure qui
est pas une extinction de masse euh tout
simplement parce qu'à l'échelle
européenne he c'est ce que j'ai surligné
ici à l'échelle européenne on atteint 50
% d'extinction donc ce qui est pas
encore suffisant pour parler
d'extinction de masse toutefois à
l'échelle du Kery on atteint quand même
67 % des enfin à l'échelle des
arciodaacyes du Kery on atteint quand
même 77 % donc pour les arciodaacyes ça
a été une période charnière ça a été un
moment très important de l'évolution de
des ancêtres des ruminants et des
ancêtres des arciodaactiles modernes de
manière générale ça a été notamment
l'époque où les les arciodaacyes sont
passés d'une d'une alimentation qui
était essentiellement dominée par le
feuillage à une alimentation
essentiellement dominée par les graminés
cette transation eosè oligocè elle est
surtout marquée par ça au niveau des
populations du du carer qu'on note
notamment ça va être un énorme niveau
d'extinction vous voyez ici chaque
couleur sur ce graphe vous avez en
nombre d'espèces vous avez le temps ici
eocè ici oligocen là et donc vous voyez
qu'à l'ocè vous avez plein de couleurs
ces couleurs présente des grand des
familles d'arciodaacyles donc vous avez
plein de couleurs et après la transition
eosè oligocè vous avez une couleur qui
domine très largement c'est les
kenotéridés donc les kenotéridé c'était
les lapins de Garen de l'oligocen c'est
c'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler un taxon
de désastre hein c'est il y a eu ça a
été le bordel et ils ont tout conquis
après ça bon ben les kenotéridés eux
c'était des mangeurs de graminé ils ont
des dents bien hpsodontes très très
hautes alors que eux c'était
essentiellement là des
des mangeurs de feuilles des mangeurs de
feuilles et de fruits mais on a aussi un
autre événement qui arrive à cette
grande coupure et cet autre événement
c'est l'arrivée de d'espèces invasives
et notamment des des espèces venues
d'Asie et en particulier des ancêtres
déruminants donc on a ce ce diagramme au
final qui nous montre que àéosè avant la
grande coupure vous aviez beaucoup
d'espèces endémique euh à l'époque àéocè
l'Europe c'est une archipelle donc c'est
plein de petites îles et sur chacune de
ces petites îles vous allez avoir une
très grande diversité de faunes
complètement endémiques donc des faunes
qui sont uniques à ce chapelet d'île
voire même unique à certaines îles
parfois et après la grande coupure en
fait vous avez une arrivée d'espèces
immigrantes qui vont essentiellement
venir d'Asie donc c cet événement en
fait il est double à savoir extinction
des espèces local et arrivé des
immigrants et et jusqu'à présent on
pensait qu'en fait c'était à cause des
espèces immigrantes que les espèces
endémiques s'étaient éteintes
c'est-à-dire que c'était l'arrivée de
ces espèces immigrantes de ces espèces
d'Asie qui avaient concurrencé les
espèces locales et avaient provoqué leur
extinction alors arrivé des espèces
immigrantes qui venaient aussi avec un
changement climatique donc euh qui
espèce immigrante qui était mieux adapté
à ce nouveau climat notamment à un
climat plus aride et plus favorable au
graminé donc vous aviez un scénario qui
était quand même bien huilé où les
immigrants suivaient le flot de graminé
qui envahissait le europeope au fur et à
mesure que le climat
s'aridifiait et les espèces endémiques
qui s'éteignaient avec le frouot
d'immigrants et bien cette nouvelle
étude proposée par l'Université de
Montpellier du coup par les chercheurs
de l'Université de Montpellier montre
qu'il y a en réalité un énorme
découplage il y a il y a un creux
gigantesque en fait entre la mort des
espèces endémiques et l'arrivée des
espèces immigrantes en réalité les
espèces immigrantes n'ont pas provoqué
l'extinction des espèces endémiques
c'est ça qu'ils nous disent ils ont en
réalité profiter de leur absence pour
immigrer donc c'est le changement
climatique seul qui a provoqué
l'extinction des espèces endémiques et
ensuite les espèces immigrantes et les
kenotteres parce que les kenotteres ne
sont pas des espèces immigrantes ce sont
des espèces locales les espèces
immigrantes et les kenotes sont ensuite
ont ensuite profité du vide pour
conquérir les niches écologiques
laissées vacrantes par ces espèces
endémiques et pour conquérir les niches
écologiques qu'on ouvert l'arrivée des
graminés donc c'est c'est une étude très
intéressante qui remet en question en
fait la dynamique de l'extinction à
cette époque et c'est très très bien
illustré par ce diagramme ici en fait où
alors c'est un peu compliqué à
comprendre mais en gros vous avez le
temps ici hein de qui parle du plus
ancien jusque là-haut au plus récent et
vous avez ici ce qu'on appelle euh
l'espace morphologique et en gros cet
espace morphologique qui est ici
représenté en bleu c'est c'est le
l'échotype on va dire de ces espèces
locales de ces espèces endémiques et
vous voyez que les espèces endémiques
elles occupent une certaine partie de
cet espace morphologique mais quand les
immigrants arrivent en fait bah les
immigrants n'occupent pas le même espace
morphologique les immigrants ne
concurrencent pas les espèces locales
c'est ça que ça veut dire voyz qu'il n'y
a pas de chevauchement ou presque pas
vous en avez juste un tout petit peu ici
mais en gros ces espèces immigrantes
quand elles arrivent ne sont pas
concurrente avec les espèces locales
parce que ell ne elles n'occupent pas le
même espace morphologique elles n'ont
pas la même morphologie elles n'ont pas
les mêmes adaptation c'est ça que
représente cet espace en deux
dimensions donc ça c'est c'est vraiment
une très très belle étude une étude très
efficace et qui nous montre la dynamique
de cette de cette extinction de la
grande coupure une dynamique qui au lieu
d'être dû aux espèces invasives était en
fait dû à un changement climatique
depuis des conditions plutôt tropicales
vers des conditions euh plus proches on
va dire d'une savane même si on peut pas
même si c'est encore trop tôt à l'époque
pour parler réellement de savane mais
des conditions plus sèches et moins
arboré mammifère toujours avec paru dans
Nature un nouvel article sur
l'extinction de gigantopitecus hein le
primate géant cousin des oranoutans euh
comme vous avez certainement entendu
parler hein le le le gigantopitecus qui
serait qui serait un cousin des
oranoutant d'après des analyses
génétiques enfin paléogénétiques qui
avaiit pu être fait directement sur les
eaux de de gigantopitecus et donc cette
analyse nous dit que gigantopitecus
Blacky euh a disparu du fait d'un
changement climatique entre 200 et
300000 ans donc changement climatique
encore une fois depuis des conditions de
jungle ù gigantopitecus en tant que
cousin de Laurent houtant se sentait
très très bien vers des conditions vous
voyez ici représenté en jaune vous voyez
que le vert qui représente la jungle
diminue et que le jaune qui représente
la la savane enfin les conditions plus
sèches augmentent et bien vous voyez que
l'arrivée de la sécheresse entre 200 et
300000 ans a provoquer l'extinction de
gigantopitecus la diminution des
populations ils ont aussi fait des
analyses des dents qui sont très
intéressantes euh puisque ces analyses
des dents montrent que les dernières
populations de de gigantopitcus avaient
des stress dentaires en réalité donc
c'est ce qui est représenté là ils ont
fait des coupes histologiques à
l'intérieur des dents et comme les dents
ont des des lignes de croissance en fait
on arrive à voir ce qui s'est passé
pendant la vie des gigantopitec et
notamment on voit que bah les les tout
derniers gigantopyc survivant avait des
lignes de croissance qui montraient des
des intervalles en fait de de croissance
rapide puis de croissance très lente
puis voilà c'était beaucoup plus
erratique alors que ça devrait être en
réalité très régulier donc ça c'est une
étude assez intéressante et vous en avez
certainement entendu parler donc je ne
m'étale pas trop dessus on reste avec
les primates avec cette nouvelle
phylogénie des primates plus de gènes
plus plus de génomees plus d'espèces et
ça nous donne une nouvelle phylogénie
des primates je vous la donne parce que
parce que c'est les primates que c'est
intéressant si vous êtes enseignant ça
peut être utile pour pour pour pour vos
cours par exemple mais ça ne change pas
grand-chose à ce qu'on savait déjà he il
y a toujours la division entre les
strepsyiniens et les aploriniens il y a
toujours la division entre les les
platiriniens et les catariniens il y a
toujours la division entre les
cercopitécoïdes et les hinoïdes donc les
les grands singes enfin les les grands
singes oui euh et puis ça donne surtout
des des des dates voyez pour les nœuds
anciens bon bah qui sont maintenant un
peu plus à jour bien que on a toujours
une une divergence entre les tarciformes
et les les singes donc les tarciformes
qui sont pas encore considérés comme
étant des singes donc la différence
entre singes et tarciforme ici qui se
fait à un peu plus de 60 millions
d'années bon c'est quand même 100
millions d'années plus vieux que le plus
vieux fossile de l'un comme de l'autre
et encore ça part du principe qu'Al
alasius est un aplorinien donc ce qui
c'est pas forcément ce qui est pas
forcément admis par tout le monde avec
une origine des primates du coup qui
tomberait juste entre 65 et 70 millions
d'années donc juste à l'extinction des
dinosaures ce qui veut dire qu'on a des
ancêtres des primates au Crétacé donc on
a effectivement
purgatorius dans le dans le Crétacé qui
est un poss possible ancêtre des
primates qui appartient au plaiadapiform
mais c'est pas encore un vrai primate
quoi donc bon c'est c'est intéressant
comme phillogénie c'est ça remet les
choses à plat mais effectivement ça ça
amène rien de très très très nouveau on
parlait de grotte tout à l'heure et dans
une grotte qui date du Permien alors
déjà vous apprendrez que oui on a des
dépôts de grottes en Amérique du Nord
qui date du Permien et dans ces dépôts
de grotte du Permien donc des des des
remplissages carstiques du Permien et
bien des chercheurs ont découvert des
fragments de peau qui appartiennent à
captorinus qui est un un des T premiers
amniotes euh du registre fossile donc
les les amniotes qui sont les ce qu'on
appelait autrefois communément les
reptiles mais qui en réalité englobent
aussi les ancêtres des mammifères donc
les les tous premiers amniotes c'était à
l'époque encore où les reptiles et les
mammifères étaient pas encore
complètement bien différenciés et la
question là l'une des grandes questions
de l'époque c'était ben du coup si on
est si on est ni entre les ni sur des ni
sur des mammifères il y avait quoi sur
leur peau hein est-ce qu'ils avaient des
des écailles en kératine qui se
chevauchaient comme des des tuiles
exactement comme les comme les lézars
modernes ou est-ce qu'à l'inverse ils
avaient des poils comme les mammifères
ou bien est-ce qu'ils avaient la ponu
comme des amphibiens et bien la réponse
c'est aucun des trois voilà on a
découvert ces ces morceaux de peau
parfaitement parfaitement préservés
carbonifié dans ses remplissages
carstiques et ces fragments de peau
montrent des écailles de kératine comme
les lézards mais elles ne se chevauchent
pas elles ne font pas comme des tuiles
donc c'est des écailles de kératine
disposé les unes à côté des autres et du
coup ça indique que c'est ça la
condition ancestrale chez les chez les
amniotes en tout cas ça indique très
fortement que c'était ça la condition
ancestrale chez les amniotes ce qui est
très très très intéressant du coup parce
que c'est la première fois qu'on arrive
à le documenter alors je dis la première
fois mais dans les dans l'article ils
exagèrent un petit peu ils exagèrent un
petit peu parce que en réalité on avait
déjà ce fossile là qui est un fossile
d'un
ancêtre des mammifères c'est un
synapside et ce synapside vous voyez il
avait aussi des écailles et lui il date
du Carbonifère il a été retrouvé voyez
c'est c'est des dépôts qui sont pas des
remplissages carstiques cette fois là
c'est c'est plus un dépôt de lagune si
je me rappelle bien mais bref vous voyez
que là on est très clairement sur
quelque chose d'écailleux et c'est aussi
des éc éaill disposé les unes à côté des
autres et pas des écailles qui se
chevauchent donc maintenant on a à la
fois captorinus qui est plutôt côté
reptile et qui a des écailles qui ne se
chevauchent pas des écailles de kératine
qui ne se chevauchent pas et on a du
coup ce varanopidé qui lui est du côté
mammifère du côté synapside et qui a des
écailles lui aussi en kératine qui ne se
chevauche pas donc maintenant on est à
peu près certain s'il restait encore un
doute que l'an être des amniotes devait
avoir la peau écailleuse exactement
comme ce que vous voyez là ce qui
confirme par la même du coup que les
poils des mamifèr sont en fait des
dérivés des écailles de ces écailles de
de ces écailles là de ces écailles qui
ne se chevauchent pas ce qu'avait déjà
proposé justement les embryologistes euh
qui travaillaient donc sur les embryons
de mammifères et de reptille et qui
avaient noté que les les placodes qui
donnent les écailles des reptiles
modernes sont les mêmes placodes qui
donnent aussi les poils au mammifères
donc on a vraiment maintenant le
registre fossile qui nous indique
exactement la même chose que ce que nous
indiquaient déjà les embryologistes et
il discutent aussi puisque dans les
mêmes dépôts ils ont aussi de la peau de
temnospondil c'est-à-dire de la peau
d'amphibien alors cette peau d'amphibien
elle est très intéressante parce qu'elle
contient des éléments usifiés vous voyez
ces baguettes là c'est de la peau
d'amphibien et dans cette peau
d'amphibien il y a des éléments usifiés
comme des baguettes ici et ça c'est
pareil c'est super intéressant parce que
ça veut dire que la peau d'Amphibia n'a
pas toujours été lisse non plus alors
est-ce que c'est des proto est-ce que
c'est quelque chose qui est juste
particulier au temnospondil ça par
contre difficile à dire et pour terminer
sans transition des invertébré avec
cette cet article sorti dans annual
reviews qui comme son nom l'indique est
une revue de la littérature sur les
échinoderme et surtout ce qu'on sait de
l'origine des échinodermes alors les
échinodermes si vous ne connaissez pas
le mot vous les connaissez forcément
quand même puisque il s'agit des oursins
des étoiles de mer des offures des
concombres de mer bref tous ces animaux
qui ont ce ce qu'on appelle une symétrie
pintaradiée c'est-à-dire que ils ont une
symétrie circulaire qui répète cinq fois
le même motif c'est faut imaginer qu'en
fait leur plan d'organisation si vous
imaginez un camamber en fait et ben
c'est un leur plan d'organisation c'est
un camamber coupé en CIN parties égales
voilà donc ça c'est le plan
d'organisation typique d'un échyoderme
qui se voit très bien sur une étoile de
mer voilà 5 bras alors 5 bras ou 10 bras
ou 15 bras ou 25 bras ou 50 bras mais
toujours un multiple de 5 on voit ça
très bien chez les oursins aussi hein
qu'ils ont qui ça ressemble vraiment à
un camambber coupé en 5 en
l'occurrence en tout cas quand vous
enlevez les épines et on voit très bien
ça aussi chez les bah chez les kinoïdes
par exemple qui ont aussi un nombre un
nombre de bras très variable mais
toujours un multiple de 5 donc ça c'est
les échinodermes les échinodermes qui
sont connus aujourd'hui pour leur
symétrie pâ à radié et ce qui m'a
vraiment intéressé avec cet article
alors au-delà du fait qu' qui nous
raconte l'origine des échinodermes dans
le registre fossile euh c'est que il
nous raconte surtout la phylogénie des
échinodermes et comment les échinodermes
en fait sont devenus les échinodermes
aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas et notamment
ils n'ont pas toujours eu de symétrie
pintaradiée vous voyez qu' ils ont
commencé en ayant une symétrie
bilatérale puis en étant asymétrique
puis en ayant une symétrie radiale alors
je vous la mets à l'horizontal
titre je vous mets l'image à
l'horizontal pardon euh ici enfin c'est
pas exactement la même image mais c'est
exactement la même philogénie et en gros
vous avez les échinodernes donc les
branches les plus basales des
échinodermes qui étaient d'abord
bilatéral alors toutes ces espècesl sont
principalement du Cambrien de
l'Ordovicien donc c'est des machins
extrêmement rares extrêmement difficile
à trouver mais qui ont été découverts
vous êtes probablement pas familiier
avec ces bêteslà donc je vais pas
m'étaler trop longtemps dessus non plus
vous commencez donc du coup par des
échinodermes qui ont d'abord une
symétrie bilatérale euh et ça c'est très
intéressant parce que ça veut dire que
la la symétrie bilatérale donc vous
connaissez certainement les bilatériens
comme nous hein nous nous avons une
symétrie bilatérale d'ailleurs en tant
que dotérostomi nous avons un ancêtre en
commun très proche avec les
échinodermes les échinodermes et et les
et les vertébrés sont groupe frère sont
très proches philogénétiquement donc
c'est pas étonnant de voir les
échinodermes commencer par une symétrie
bilatérale et ce qui fait deux des
échinodermes à ce moment-là sachant
qu'ils n'ont pas encore cette simétipe
interradié bah c'est leur c'est leur de
calcite donc des plaques de calcite qui
sont très typiques des
échinodermes donc les premiers
échinodermes sont à symétrie bilatérale
vous voyez qu'il y a un bel axe de
symétrie qui va d'antérieur à postérieur
ici et sont des formes fixes ce sont des
formes qui ne se promènent pas
d'ailleurs toutes les formes qui sont
représentées là il me semble sont toutes
fixes toutes les tous les échinodermes
de lordordovicien de du Cambrien de
lordordovicien sont sont attachés au
pied vous voyez qu'ils ont tous un petit
pied là attaché à leur substrat le le
déplacement comme les étoiles de mer et
les oursins il se déplacent très
lentement mais ils se déplacent ça ne
viendra qu'après donc là à cette époque-
làà ils sont tous ils sont tous attachés
et au début ils ont cette symétrie
bilatérale qui va ensuite devenir
asymétrique voyez que les les cyctes et
les solutes sont des échinodermes
toujours attachés au pied mais qui
deviennent légèrement asymétriques vous
voyez par exemple ici notamment que les
plaques euh ne forment pas un axe de
symétrie donc ils deviennent d'abord
asymétrique puis chez helélicoplacus ils
deviennent à symétrie triiradiale donc
la symétrie triradiale vous imaginez
qu'il y a trois c'est un camamber en
fait hélicoplacus c'est un camamber
coupé en trois et ensuite vous l'étendez
en tournant comme ça en faisant une
espèce de spirale et ça vous donne
helélicoplacus donc vous l'étendez en
tournant et ça vous donne un camber
coupé en tro tordu en fait et étendu en
cylindre c'est un peu compliqué à
s'imaginer mais c'est ça helélicoplacus
et donc vous avez d'abord la symétrie
triradiale et symétrie triiradiale qui
va ensuite chez hellicocystis devenir
une symétrie
pintaadiale donc une symétrie par 5 mais
toujours en
spirale donc d'abord une symétrie
triradiale en spirale puis une symétrie
pintaradiale en spirale pour ensuite
arriver à la vraie symétrie pintaradiale
qu'on retrouve chez les échinodermes
modernes et je trouve ce scénario
évolutif de la folie c'est c'est ouf en
fait d'être passé par donc commencer par
la symétrie bilatérale de tous les
bilatériens la perdre acquérir une
symétrie triiradiale en spirale acquérir
une symétrie pint radiale en spirale
pour ensuite finir sur une symétrie pint
radiale euh bon pas pas parfaite puisque
tous les échinodermes modernes n'ont pas
une symétrie pintaradiale parfaite
notamment les les oursins irréguliers
comme leur nom l'indique mais c'est
juste
waouh la contingence de les l' évolution
mesdames et messieurs l'évolution qui
fait du n'importe quoi et qui improvise
son n'importe quoi par au-dessus le
n'importe quoi qui a eu avant ça c'est
c'est du jus pour créationniste il est
où le dessin intelligent là-dedans là
vas-y
là c'est du jus antiréationniste mais à
l'état pur quoi c'est explique-moi la
logique
vas-y qui a dit ce serait une super idée
de faire ça de passer par toutes ces
étapes là pour atteindre du
pintaradial
moi je trouve ça énorme je trouve ça
absolument énorme c'est pas la peine au
fait c'est pas la peine de me demander
en quoi c'est avantageux d'être pint
radial j'en ai aucune idée j'en ai
absolument aucune idée cet article ne le
dit pas et je pense que la raison pour
laquelle cet article ne le dit pas c'est
parce qu'il y a pas de raison évidente
et bref je sais pas par où sont passés
les échinodermes pour subir tout ça mais
ils ont dû en voir des choses cheloues
pour en arriver là
voilà c'était Palo news je vous remercie
de l'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner pour ne rien manquer d'ancien et
je vous dis à très
[Musique]
bientôt